kitty
is
you there sir did dakota send you
that's right you got the goods
right here dino our super kidney
especially for sickle cell anemics just
like we agreed
hey these will get to you yep yes later
i know
i have to go now i'm operating
beating our ass
give him hell
holy [ __ ]
i'm sad
no [ __ ] no
don't shoot don't shoot i won't
if you can give me an explanation and it
better be [ __ ] good
the phone call with dakota it was tapped
the police
they made me do it nice try the badges
wouldn't go into all that trouble over a
kidney implant
wait please it's the truth they said
they were rounding up
every last raffin shift member in night
city
but dakota isn't oh [ __ ] it never mind
you won't get it please let me go i
i didn't want to get mixed up in this i
had no choice
unlike the badges i don't kill people
without a good reason
oh god thank you
thank you you should be thanking me
not god isn't that what docs always say
wait wait
the super kidney the police put a virus
onto it
use the firmware from this shard if you
want the patient to live
your honesty is much appreciated
it it's the least i owed you this better
be worth it
um
there's
so
business
is
[Music]
[Music]
i got jake's implant but there's a virus
on it he'll have to swap out his
firmware with the original on the shard
what a surprise no nomads always get
special treatment thanks for being
careful
come by in a few hours things should
settle down by then
how's jake doing he's easing into it
slowly
needs a day or two to get up on his feet
i'm glad to hear that
you have my thanks b on behalf of myself
and the entire family